yeah i think for most people let's just
go back to what you enjoyed as a kid
or go do go work on things that you'd
work on for free did you
like do you follow james altucher
because that's something that i've heard
him say a lot
i like james yeah james is a friend yeah
like one of the things that i heard him
say i was at this conference a few years
ago and
you know he was there with his ex-wife
at the time and he was talking about how
you know you like have these have this
like idea sex so you just mash up two
ideas and like
what did you do when you're like 11 or
12 years old and you lost track of time
sort of thing it's like
yeah that's how you know it sounds very
reminiscent of those uh
narratives maybe it's a jewish thing i
don't know but i think
generally it's like if you want to make
the most money possible just go find the
thing you can work on for free forever
what does that mean when when jews say
it must be a jewish thing because i used
to have this jewish roommate when i was
younger
you actually remind me a lot of them
like he's like he's gone on to become a
very successful lawyer now but we got on
great when i lived with the guy like
what does that mean it's a jewish thing
do you ever meet jews i don't know if
other people who are not jewish people
live with the jew you can kind of tell
they're a little different right
a little like oh they're getting
different a little different no they're
like
hyper they're like i have to go and do
this come on let's go it's like where's
my riddle
yeah we probably invented ritalin
probably right
um and well to be clear i think there's
also a very interesting distinction
about an american jew versus an israeli
jew what's the difference
an israeli jew is just a little more
hutzpah a little bit more pressing they
live in a smaller environment they're
even they're more
extreme uh in terms of direct like
they're like hey
and in the language is like i'm learning
hebrew a lot of language in hebrew is
like it's all contractions
like you know in america we have this
like israel is like yo we're a small ass
country
we used to have more enemies around us
we don't have enough time to like deal
with like a lot of stuff so it's like
contractions
immediacy um
it's an interesting culture i think in
terms of judaism
when you say it's a jew thing i i i
think one of the best words my friends
call me is neurotic
and i i think it stems from you know
judaism is kind of a culture based on
community and
based on questions like our the culture
is encouraging to ask
a [ __ ] ton of questions and it's like
why is that what do you do this for and
that's kind of what we're
we're taught why why why like keep
asking why over again yeah yeah
yeah the jews do that and then you know
we have these kind of women in our
culture my mom
that just a very unique breed of woman
like overbearing
imposing loving strong just
very specific that i think create these
certain type of men
i don't know how to describe myself but
definitely uh a little different
you have a um i just sort of your videos
by popularity you have one here on the
top looks like
five mr steel yo pennies why
jewish people are taking over the world
that one didn't seem to do so well with
the like to dislike ratio i
i understand that's a video i'm not sure
i would put out today not something i
want to get into or like
debate with other people i was in israel
i was living in israel at the time
okay i'm happy to talk about it it's
just interesting that this one culture
and
there are um conspiracy theories like
you can look on wikipedia
there's a lot of dudes that will blame
the jews for everything yeah yeah also
there's conspiracy theories why are the
ashkenazis the the lighter-skinned jews
so successful so do i know i don't know
the answer
you